are you finding yourself becoming more
spiritual with age or are you still just
looking at everything and thinking we're
all just machines within machines and
well I I think
um yes I'm becoming more spiritual as it
goes in because you rise and you sort of
see things in perspective you learn more
but the mechanics is not the
inconsistent with the spirituality
spirituality to me means
um a connectedness with the whole
essentially the rising you know above
yourself and realizing that you're part
of this whole and and that beautiful
acceptance but that whole works in kind
of a mechanical way some things we know
about some things we don't know about
but it is that okay it's like the life
Arc and it's like all of those things
you know there is still cause effect
relationships so when I say machine I
just mean that there are causes to
everything that happens